bonjour jacques smith merci de répondre
à nos questions quelles sont les mesures
qui ont été adoptées par le gouvernement
et qui n'ont pas fonctionné notamment
deux euros par jour
deux repas par jour à 1 euro vous avez
déjà la première chose à dire c'est que
cette enquête elle arrive elle arrive
tardivement les différentes choses qui
sont pour un thé du doigt dans cette
enquête réalisée effectivement en tout
cas qu'on a vu hier c'est la détresse
effectivement c'est le manque
d'accompagnement de la part du
gouvernement c'est le manque aussi de de
tout simplement le on sent que la
génération notre génération la jeunesse
et sa clique et par le gouvernement le
manque d'attention que couleurs n'ont
pas avoir auprès de la jeunesse et
aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu c'est depuis
un an
depuis plus d'un an même que le début de
la crise sanitaire a dit bernard fait
des propositions justement pour la
jeunesse vous dit que ça n'a pas
fonctionné qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné et que faudrait-il faire la
place qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
savez typiquement le ticket
effectivement à les deux euros par jour
que vous prêtez du droit qui est en fait
le repas le repas un euro au départ tu
dois peut-être vous le vous le
mentionnez s'il n'était ouvert qu'aux
boursiers malheureusement et grâce aussi
à notre travail on a pu l'ouvrir à
l'ensemble de la population étudiante
est pourquoi il n'était pas cette mesure
n'est pas suffisante et largement
largement insuffisante c'est que les
crous n'était pas ouvert beaucoup de
coups seront réouverts mais beaucoup
beaucoup de croûtes n'était pas encore
ouvert à l'époque et donc serre par un
des leurs qui est distribué dans les
restaurants universitaires net ne
pouvait pas d'être à disposition des
étudiants pour chier et non boursiers et
on a réussi à l'ouvrir désormais à
l'ensemble de la population puisque
l'ensemble de la population étudiante
notamment ceux issus des classes
moyennes qui ne sont pas boursiers de
bénéficier patte de toutes ces mesures
et autres ça qu'est ce que vous proposez
en plus pour améliorer la santé morale
des des étudiants alors deux choses
principales 1 toujours en lien avec ce
qu'on vient de dire puisque
effectivement comme vous venez de le
dire ce sera par un euro était un peu le
la mesure phare du gouvernement en lien
avec cette précarité étudiante
l'uni propose la mise en place d'un
ticket restaurant étudiants de
proposition de loi une à l'assemblée une
au sénat sont en cours celle au sénat va
même être en examen en juin
ce ticket restaurant
dix ans qui permettraient tout
simplement à l'ensemble des étudiants de
se restaurer à faire leurs courses dans
l'ensemble des commerces pour pour tout
simplement pouvoir se restaurer à tarif
étudiant partout et notamment durant
cette note de crise
et puis deuxièmement vous savez la santé
mentale on n'a pas attendu cette enquête
pour savoir effectivement voilà à peu
près de près d'un quart et même
peut-être plus maintenant on déjà penser
effectivement à se suicider cet étudiant
sion on dit ce qu'on savait déjà a
oscillé s'inquiéter trouvent sur leur
santé mentale est donc aujourd'hui la
seule et unique solution saas à cette
malheureuse ce malheureux constat c'est
la réouverture des universités et c'est
pour ça qu'on demande aujourd'hui
gouvernement de préparer la rentrée
prochaine
ce que ce que le gouvernement n'avait
pas le faire pour la rentrée 2020
malheureusement vous parler de la santé
mort des étudiants 42 % des étudiants
ont une pensée suicidaire presque un
étudiant sur deux c'est énorme
est ce que ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur l'avenir du pays parce
que les étudiants d'aujourd'hui sont les
travers de demain clairement ça fait
depuis un an et demi qu'on dit au
gouvernement et vous savez quand en
novembre et décembre derniers à la noce
du second confinement les l'immense et
l'ensemble des étudiants sont sont
effectivement moralement touché quand en
décembre tout un plan comme unité soir
avaient été faits par le gouvernement
pour nous expliquer qu'il y aura du
présentiel à partir du présentiel à
partir de 2 janvier que la première
conférence de presse du premier ministre
jean castex le 7 janvier on se souvent
s'en souvient tous tous les étudiants
s'en souviennent aucun mot pas un seul
pas un seulement par rapport aux
étudiants et à la jeunesse sur sur ce 7
janvier sur cette conférence de presse
on a bien vu qu'après le mois dès le
mois de janvier a été une à moi
épouvantable avec eux avec avec des
sushis d une santé vous sentez très
compliqué à gérer pour les étudiants
donc aujourd'hui en effet c'est la rue
ouverte aux diversités et travailler dès
maintenant sur la sur la rentrée
prochaine pour que l'année 2000 21 2022
puisse être une une année où on pense
aux diplômes des étudiants à leur
insertion professionnelle à leur
réussite puisque c'est aussi de ça qui
est donc il faut qu'on parle merci
jacques smith d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
délégué national du syndicat étudiant
uni
l'union nationale inter universitaire